this was eighty two page document which
is two different body cam transcripts
filed in District Court and Minnesota
ten days ago or so actually same day the
Harper Center came out looks like and
yeah it's it's audio transcripts from
two of the police officers involved and
what I what I was able to do I read
through them and went back and looked at
a little bit of the video and was able
to map on a little bit in one of the
cases to sort of where and the
transcript we're seeing because it's
it's hard to know without any sound or
anything it's hard to know what is
actually going on when yeah in this
transcript but what what what do you see
well I see a number of things so first
of all this covers a lot of territory
that I spoke to Joe Rogan about that we
disagreed over the interpretation of and
so now we know a lot of the answers that
we were speculating on back then and I
will just say I've read through the
transcript and certain things one
there's no indication that Chauvin and
Floyd recognized that they knew each
other if they knew each other at all
right so there's no dialogue between
them that seems like people who know
each other I don't see anything in there
about race there's no overt racism in
the transcript doesn't mean it's not
there on people's minds but it doesn't
show up there excited delirium does show
up but it shows up late in the
interaction so probably doesn't play a
role as important as I suspected it
might I wasn't able to figure out early
throughout the interaction Floyd is
saying things like about claustrophobia
I'm choking I can't breathe but before I
as far as I can tell before any officers
are on him and he says things like my
face is gone and and then what you can't
hear in the video that we all saw but
you see in these transcripts this
discussion between officers is you know
is busy intoxicated what kind of pipe
was that do we think it's PCP yeah
and what what you see again is no no
mention of race between the officers at
least from these two transcripts yeah
but what does appear to be a description
a discussion of them trying to figure
out what is going on with this guy and
how it is that they can do what they
need to do it seems like well really
trying not to hurt him well look I'm no
expert yeah police stuff but I do want
to say in the transcript it is clear a
that George Floyd complains about not
being able to breathe before he's on the
ground B that the officers don't prefer
to put him on the ground they want to
put him in the car he won't go and
actually he asks to be put on the ground
right
so I you've said that I didn't I didn't
see that in these scratch strips and I
read I read through it fast but you know
so Floyd talks about you know this just
happened to me I don't want to get shot
and you know there's a whole lot in in
what he says that we can imagine and you
know I I just simply don't know the
truth of his history but we could
certainly imagine that he is beyond
spooked by the prospect of agreeing to
demands by police when he he doesn't
disagree when they say that he's passed
a fake bail I guess is why they were
called to the scene but that doesn't
mean just because he did either nothing
wrong to begin with or something trivial
wrong that doesn't mean that something
bad won't happen to him so you know is
he legitimately you know worried and
alarmed and saying things that are
incoherent maybe but he's also so
incoherent and so unwilling to respond
to what appear to be very moderate
requests that that they're the police
are being pushed and pushed and pushed
well I don't know they want to put him
in the car yeah he doesn't want to go in
the car he wants to do on the ground and
why do they want to put him in the car
for having passed a fake bill well I
don't know yeah I don't know you know I
don't know enough about the law I mean
obviously passing a fake bill you know
potentially we're talking about a
counterfeiter right obviously a $20 bill
is not a major Madol matter but
counterfeiting is a federal crime I
don't know
I don't pretend to know but but the
point is I mean I think the real point
is this the transcript is complex right
there are lots of things in play here
what we all saw on video was very
troubling but what it actually means is
unclear right what you need in order to
figure out what it means is a court that
is free to engage in navigating those
issues to have experts on the law on
normal police procedure on procedure
under special circumstances on the drugs
that appear to have been in his system
and whether or not they were present at
the moment that he was being arrested or
this was a trace toxicity as drogon
suggests it might be you want to know
those things and you want to have a
court free to navigate these things but
above and beyond the fact that the
transcript does reflect a an environment
that has a lot of things going on in
which a court would need to navigate
here's the thing that is most troubling
to me that link to the document was sent
to me by a friend right we both thought
it did not exist in the world on trying
to figure out if the document was
authentic it was on a New York Times
server right and so the questions will
is it authentic it wise it on a new year
time server it became quickly apparent
that had been published a couple days
prior by the New York Times they had
written a story on it and they had
linked the document and it was sitting
there on their server so it is
legitimate but here's the question
why was it not a huge story why was you
given all that is happening downstream
of George Floyd's tragic death why was
the contents of the transcript not on
everybody's mind because many of the
things that have been said about the
arrest are I don't want to say testable
in a scientific sense but they can be
compared to the transcript and we can
actually have answers about what took
place and there seemed to be very little
interest in having that discussion for
some reason and it's very hard for me to
imagine I would have thought the
emergence of that transcript would
immediate
they have trended on Twitter it would
have been the focus of the news cycle
for 24 hours if not more and there would
have been all kinds of discussion and
instead somehow the social environment
I think treated it as not important and
I worry that it treated is not important
because it was complex rather than a
simple story of murder yeah it is
complex I've got I've got a piece
highlighted here in which the officer is
trying to officer Lane I guess in this
case is trying to get Floyd to get out
of the car and we can't necessarily tell
it looks like he's so I doesn't want to
do it and he's not doing it and the
officer keeps saying get out of the car
and the woman who is shavonda Renae
he'll finally says stop resisting Floyd
and this is this is early in the
interaction but you know one of one of
the people whom Floyd is with is reading
what is happening as Floyd resisting the
officers what appear
you know I'm reading into this but it
would appear from her comment here that
she is reading what her friend
acquaintance whatever Floyd is doing as
resistance that is not warranted by the
situation it's it's complex like you
said yeah it's complex but it doesn't
mean it's not murder but you know again
we have a structure that deals with this
it's called a court it makes findings of
fact and findings of law it does so on
the basis of evidence and what we now
have is a situation in which the public
perception that it knows what it saw on
that video that that is sufficient to
determine what took place is it's a
grave danger you know it is a grave
danger to our system to the extent that
what we end up doing is using our courts
to validate public perception basically
getting them to rubber-stamp
the court of public opinions judgment
that is again the uninvent of America if
if this is clear then allow it to be
found so in a court rather than assuming
that the court has only one choice
because the answer is so simple
[Music]